Hi! We will continue the last example from the
previous video, and this time when we will click on the "force load track 0" or "force load track 2" buttons.
You remember the track number 0 (the English subtitles) was not loaded, readyState=0
here says the track is not loaded. Track 2 also was not loaded: it contains
the English chapters of the video. This time, I will explain how we can read
the content of the file. So if I click on "force load track 0", I see
here the content of the WebVTT file. I didn't read it as pure text, I used the
track API for accessing individually each cue, each one of these elements here is a cue,
and I access the id, the start time, the end time and the content, that we call the text content
of each cue. If I click on "force load track 2", I see the
chapters definitions here, so chapter 1 of the video goes from 0 to 26 seconds, and it
corresponds to the introduction part of the video.
How did we do that? We just completed the readContent function that previously just
showed the statuses of the different tracks. So remember that when we clicked on a button,
we forced the text track corresponding to the HTML track to be loaded in memory,
and then we can read it. A TextTrack object has different properties
and the most important one is called cues. The cues is the list of every cue inside the VTT file,
and each cue corresponds to a time segment, has an id and a text content.
If you do track.cues, you've got the list of the cues and you can iterate on them.
So for each cue, we are going to get its id: cue.id here. It corresponds to the id of the
cue number i. In my example, I have got an index in the loop, I get the current cue,
I get the id of this cue. I can also get the start time, the end time
and the text. So cue.text corresponds exactly at this sentence
highlighted here. This is the only thing I wanted to show you,
because the next time we are going to do something really interesting with this content here,
we are going to display on the side of the video a clickable transcript. And when we will
click on it, the video will jump to the corresponding position. This is exactly what the edX video
player does, the one you are watching at right now.